hi Friday I'm in Hawaii but the week
didn't start this way if you don't know
if fried areas fried areas look back at
my weekend blog forum so let's take a
look back at how I ended up here none of
the stuff in the beginning of the week
actually contributed to why I'm here
they were all separate moments in time
why I'm here with a pre thought-out
independent ly planned thing
so let's look back at my weak tie your
face is tired I'll make a face has old
makeup on it hi friary it is Monday
night um I am about responding I am
responding to emails right now I'm
drinking a martini I am doing laundry I
am cleaning things up getting [ __ ] done
in the classiest way possible America
today was really fun
Hannah and I did a photo shoot for only
I can tell you yet but it'll be out soon
on a shoot right now - you think -
you've got the pills have to feel yeah
check that we're friends for buds we're
buddies from there I went to a fitting
for a shoot that I'm doing with Marriott
that I'm really really excited about I'm
in a building for a fitting for a
shooting doing tomorrow at Marriott and
I don't know where the first to go this
was all right wait there's that one -
help
[Applause]
I'm shooting the series of commercials
with them that they let me help right
with them which is so cool because four
five years ago I have been auditioning
for commercials for so many years in New
York and then three years after
auditioning I finally booked a Lowe's
commercial and I did these series of
Lowe's commercials kind of as myself
before I was doing YouTube but myself
that I was a Lowe's employee in these
commercials so not really myself so
everything I just said was a lie now I
am doing a bunch of Marriott commercials
as a character of Marriott that is
myself still but this time around they
let me help write them this is so
different I'm so excited and the shoot
is happening tomorrow so I'll film as
much as I can there we're on set for
Marriott right now yeah this makes sense
look who's here Wendy
here all of these other people are here
uh and that looks almost like a real
pool there you camera all Marriott have
a camera right by their pool in case you
want to shoot a commercial about their
hotel I'm on lunch
[Music]
yeah hello we're on set day two of a
shoot with Marriott and look where we
got beautiful my amorous glamour
especially right down the road from
where we shot capture Kota it's a
billion and a half degrees business
that's business that's business
happening it was a very business do
another match in business that's a
business hat everyone here is a cat damn
professional let's look at some of the
props insert made my heart joke hello
friary it is Thursday and it is um
Thursday
I just went to Denny's yeah I didn't get
Denny's takeout I just ordered way too
much food at Denny's and then took it to
go and now I'm running some errands
because tomorrow I'm going to Hawaii for
fourth of July it's partially vacation
and mostly a way to get me to get
writing done and remove me from the
world of stimulus so right now I'm just
doing some errands before leaving very
early tomorrow morning wow what a
[Music]
lovely stimulating conversation we are
having today and I didn't bring
sunglasses with me some my face feels
nude oh and don't mind this Princess
Leia a cat on the couch next you oh is
that a pillow of her face who do you
think you are being tart
I see it too don't worry you're not
gonna crazy
it is um Thursday night I went for a run
I'm making dinner I'm making meatballs
and this sauce thing that I heard that
you can make really delicious meatball
sauce with just grape jelly and chili
sauce so I'm testing it out all the
teenagers that watch me how cool am I
getting ready to go to Hawaii tomorrow
morning the one thing I want to tell you
guys is that today the official poster
for electro Medina girl has dropped as
the kids say I here it is haha and
Hannah Hart and I will be going to Comic
Con
we're doing I think some signings there
and some panels and if you want all the
information you can go to this website
or you can just follow a legendary on
Twitter doesn't give you all of the
information but let me know if you guys
are into comic-con we'd love to see you
I've never been to the comic-con part of
comic-con last year I went and got to do
a show an at midnight show but that was
in a theater away from the convention
center so I've never actually been in
the convention center so this year is
the year let's do it things smell like
they're burning so I'm going to go
[Music]
this is the car or anything exact check
into them well there you go there's all
the things that have happened to me this
week um I hope that that entertained you
on some level if it didn't there's gotta
be another video online that'll make you
happy
and if there isn't I don't know lines
loves gasoline
would never get on the plane
and go to Hawaii
I wish that
I can hardly believe it either